[Musique]
c'est un mauvais virus mais ça aurait pu être
bien pire c'est presque comme un bon
essai si je n'arrive pas à avoir de l'eau ça va
parce que je sais que j'ai plusieurs mois d'
eau à la maison ça n'arrive pas si
tu  es un préparateur tu n'as pas à faire
partie de cette foule folle qui court
partout en essayant d'envelopper du papier toilette et de l'
eau sincère ne dis pas mouvement panique
una decisión téléphones Oh maman comme Chris
Duke Oviedo poète en voix o menos Zetas
quand Alonzo suficiente  préparez-vous un
ventre paresseux Preppers satan bones do
survivalism le Preppers monarchie littérale
fils d'argile d'argile onze femmes n'associent pas
e-911 qui a été l'année la plus folle de
tous
les temps ouais mm même pas proche je
veux dire 2020 est l'année à retenir tu
as ça à  au moins tu sais hé je peux
boire de la rivière c'est délicieux
je pense qu'il a tué la dinde transporter des
visiteurs rhymine unique non américain
défavorisé un décret de consentement passé les
phénomènes de Ramallah ont introduit d'autres une
communauté se prépare séparément est venu dessus
ça pourrait b  e dans la rivière Gregor Blanco
Pancho Villa
- Ramon
pensez-vous que vous pouvez manquer d'
électricité aux États-Unis Je pense que c'est très
probable que cela se produira probablement
car les grandes villes perdront de l'énergie
à cause d'une cyberattaque ou d'
une impulsion magnétique electra Matic ou quelque chose qui va
pour être un peu plus large ouais
ouais le réseau tombe en panne s'il n'y a pas d'
électricité dans trois jours il n'y
aura plus de nourriture et les histoires
peuvent Facebook ou Instagram alors ils perdent
la tête ouais deviennent fous d'accord alors
nous allons  testez demain et j'ai une
étincelle qui est un peu
plus de nuit assez douce mais il a une tige Ferro dans la
poignée donc c'est plutôt doux et
puis nous avons aussi le bâton de corde phat
donc c'est essentiellement un allume-feu nous
allons  testez ça et voyez comment
ça marche bien je les ai vus faire ça faisait
en fait ça pour le fluff là-
haut elle souffle en
fait cette tige était plutôt bonne pouvez-
vous savoir que vous savez pour être ce petit
jeez vous pouvez obtenir facilement  y 30 incendies à partir de
ce truc, c'est vraiment cool, j'aime
ça en plus c'est un
appareil de filtration d'eau personnel qui, en gros, toutes les
bactéries, il enlèvera 99,9 et et na
90% de cela, en gros, il suffit d'aller le
remplir avec de l'eau et  Je vais vous montrer comment
cela fonctionne
cette vis directement pouvez-vous le boire
c'est délicieux c'est délicieux est-
ce qu'il a bon goût je vous laisserais l'
essayer s'il n'y avait pas convoiter
19 je veux dire qui sait dans des moments
comme  ça avec kovat 19 il n'y a pas d'
eau tu ne peux pas aller à l'épicerie
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire et si tu as
ça au moins tu sais hé je peux boire
de la rivière si j'en ai besoin ouais tu
sais si je dois venir  ici avec mon
camp familial parce que la ville est folle tu
sais que le virus devient fou alors je peux
venir ici nous savons que nous avons de l'eau nous savons que
nous avons de la nourriture nous savons que nous avons un moyen d'
allumer un feu et nous sommes prêts à partir je pense  vous
êtes probablement la première personne que vous avez
dans la maison depuis probablement plus d'un mois
juste à cause de t  o la pandémie et vous savez
essayer de garder la famille aussi en sécurité que
possible, alors bienvenue, hey girlies les poulets
sont c'est très intentionnel c'est
encore une fois très délibéré c'est juste une autre chose
qui peut aider à garder la famille en sécurité,
surtout à une époque comme celle-ci comme cette
pandémie c'est  une autre chose que si nous
devions vous savez que nous pourrions simplement rester
et manger des œufs nous avons parlé de la préparation
tout le temps ils comprennent ce que c'est
pour les bons gars vous savez ce que
nous faisons pourquoi préparons-nous non pourquoi le faisons-nous
ouais  serveur sûr pour garder la famille en sécurité
hein les
gars, rappelez-vous pourquoi nous avons le
plan d'urgence le plan
en cas de catastrophe ouais pourquoi au cas où nous serions séparés comme à l'
école si quelque chose se passe s'il y a une
catastrophe dans cette école quoi d'autre ouais les
choses bien quoi d'autre faisons-nous  besoin d'
ajouter à celui-là maintenant une pandémie, je
ne sais pas pourquoi nous n'avons pas mis cela
avant de ne pas y penser, alors
passons en revue tout cela très
rapidement, quelles sont les voies d'évacuation de
notre maison si  il y a un feu à quatre portes
qu'est-ce qui marche où celui-là alors
[Musique]
si nous devons partir très vite donc nous
avons chacun un sac qui contient des trucs
dont nous pourrions avoir besoin tu veux lui montrer
ce que tu as chez tes gars  retour d'accord
il a une boussole un sifflet correspond aux
instructions de premiers secours un crayon à lame de rasoir mon
analgésique à l'aspirine donc cela a quelques
maths supplémentaires - lampe de poche avec une
radio d'urgence les gens disent à propos des
Preppers qu'ils sont vous savez paranoïaque
ou pour moi encore c'est juste un peu  un peu de
tranquillité d'esprit et je pense que les enfants sont
moins paniqués parce qu'ils nous en avons
parlé avant nous avons parlé de
pandémie nous avons parlé de catastrophes naturelles dont
nous avons parlé vous savez
les effondrements économiques tous ces trucs fous
qui  se produisent donc cela ne les
surprend pas vraiment et j'ai vu un groupe d'entre
vous savez que les gens s'inquiètent ou que leurs enfants
ont peur de Kovan 19 et les nôtres
n'ont pas peur si quelque chose se passait et
je n'étais pas capable de m'en occuper  les gars
et je n'étais pas un  ble de garder tout le monde en sécurité
et en bonne santé et nourri et arrosé, vous savez que
ce serait horrible
[Musique]
si les choses tournaient vraiment mal Je pense qu'une
arme à feu est l'élément de défense ultime
que vous pouvez avoir Je ne veux jamais l'
utiliser sur un humain  mais nous
considérons toujours le fait que vous devrez peut-être l'
utiliser en défense J'ai un pistolet et
puis j'ai deux fusils de chasse et deux
fusils de petit calibre c'est juste une autre
police d'assurance ce n'est pas différent de
la nourriture ou de l'eau ou des médicaments
c'est une autre  forme d'assurance en tant que
préparateur en tant qu'Américain ou quoi que ce soit d'
important halète cette chose
tire tellement plus doucement que ce dernier
pistolet, le pistolet est le grand égaliseur dans
tout type de combat, alors j'espère que c'est
suffisant pour effrayer les gens et dire
bonjour  tu ne veux pas venir ici tu
ne veux pas t'occuper de ça c'est
l'espoir évidemment mais tu sais que nous l'
avons si nous en avons besoin et c'est une
bonne chose je pense qu'il a tué la
caméra de dinde et ces cibles que nous connaissons c'est
c'est ça  dîner de nksgiving juste là,
le honker PCAT est devenu un
billet d'essence honoraire pour Sampat initialement proposé
fiabilité écovillage Ansari jouer SD la
peur du succès est le consul Everest
au scénario apocalyptique bienvenue dans le
podcast décontracté des Preppers le seul endroit
pour préparer la survie et l'intérêt
nous sommes vos hôtes Kobe vous  prêt à
apporter la bonté de survie directement à vos
trous d'oreille
nous sommes prêts à apporter la bonté de survie
directement à vos trous d'oreille mm-hmm
divertissement pour cette quarantaine ouais
tu es prêt cam es-tu excité
parce que je suis excité nous parlons de
kovat depuis quoi deux mois  au moins maintenant un
peu plus de deux mois, cela devient de plus en plus
fou si nous examinons le nombre total de
cas confirmés dans le monde, deux
millions, c'est insensé, je pense que la première
fois que nous avons fait ces chiffres, nous avions comme
40 000 ou quelque chose comme ça et ça
continue juste à  grandir j'ai l'impression que cette année
est comme le plateau d'échantillonnage
ouais c'est htlm est un événement shtf c'est vraiment que
tu es sur le tremblement de terre  J'aime
pas oh c'est essayer de pandémique oh tu aimes
ça essayons un peu plus d'effondrement
essayons tu sais c'est comme bien et
puis en plus de tout ça on a une
élection présidentielle en même temps
donc c'est comme l'année la plus folle comme  J'avais
toujours l'habitude de dire tu sais que le 11 septembre a
été l'année la plus folle de tous les temps ouais c'est
2001 ouais même plus proche
je veux dire 2020 est l'année à retenir
[Musique]